Well, hey. I'm, I'm Jason Morgan. I'm a
technical evangelist with Voyant, and just means it's
my job to talk to folks about Linkerd,
encourage them to try it out, and help
them be successful once they get on that
path. Yeah. And I'm Catherine Panganini. I'm the
head of marketing and community at Buoyant,
and I will work with Jason on Link4D,
but also on the cloud native glossary, something
one of our pet projects that we created
together and are very proud of. So
yeah. Yeah. So, you're asking about what the
cloud native glossary is. So it was it's
it
it's a glossary of terms, but it's not
as boring as it sounds, I promise. Or
it's really boring but still helpful. So our
intent was as we're as we kinda got
together and started working together, you know, before
working together at Buoyant Right. Right, we'd we'd
each spend a lot of time trying to
explain to folks
concepts
around Kubernetes and cloud native and like, if
you've ever had to talk to your friends
or people in your self circle about about
this space,
you'll find a lot of the terms don't,
like, don't have meaning to a lot of
people. Right? And
the glossary was an attempt to take
terms like service mesh, container,
you know, gate API gateway. It was a
pure team. Yeah. Yeah. Was their ability. All
the same.
Make them
easy to understand in plain language.
And
the English part's good, but the really exciting
part is Oh, yeah. So we are we
have several localization teams that are localizing the
glossary in I don't know how many languages
now, but we have Chinese,
Korean, Spanish, Portuguese,
French. Oh, French is not live yet. Spanish
and I don't know. Probably missing something. The
Hindi one's live. Oh, Hindi. Yeah. So very
excited about that. And
I think one of the important things, especially
for someone who is with my background who
does not have a technical background,
it's really
hard to understand cloud native. There is no
context. And most of the content out there
really assumes a lot of context that people
like me don't have. And so one thing
that was important for me when we created
LostRay was to
lighten a way that people like me can
understand, because there are a lot of people
who need to understand it
and are not technologists. You have all the
people who are working in cloud native companies,
marketing, sales, but the leadership team too who
are ultimately taking and making all these decisions
about whether
to
fund
project
which is very expensive. And so if they
don't understand it, you cannot talk to your
leadership team about
these projects. How how can they make these
decisions? So so the goal is not only
to educate technical people but also nontechnical people.
And I feel like it's good, like the
way they're described,
it's accessible for both. Right? Like, if you're
just getting started, a technical person will appreciate
the easy, digestible language, but it's all it's
not excluding nontechnical people as well. I think
that's a great I think that's a great
explanation. So I heard a couple questions in
there. Right? Like, is the glossary done? No.
Right? Absolutely not. And it it won't get
done. And what we'd really love is for
folks
for folks that are good at understanding and
explaining technical terms, if you have some time
and some bandwidth, look at our look at
look at the definitions that are out there.
If they can be improved, send PRs.
If there's something missing, you know, create an
entry. If you're a business or if you
are in the space and and you use
a lot of terms, but you don't necessarily
have them defined, don't go write your own
glossary and definitions.
Link to the cloud native glossary.
You know, and then whatever whatever language is
your native tongue, right, if it's not English,
you know, we would love to see love
to see cloud native become
accessible.
And that sounds terrible, not as I We
love the the tooling and the technology
to become more accessible to more folks. Make
it a broader audience. Not not so much
for like specialized
engineers
that really love Kubernetes and containers, but make
it for people that are just trying to
get things done with computers.
Alright? And make it easier for those folks.
So I think I answered a lot of
your questions.
Yeah. And think
one one of the important things is the
glossary is really a living document. Right? Like,
things change all the time. Technology changes all
the time. Right. That's why it's like, it's
it's not good to have like, if you
see definitions
now out there,
most of them are vendor provided,
which is actually really bad because
vendors might be biased towards their own product,
they may not keep it up to date,
you know. There are lots of issues with
it. So like having a glossary
that is vendor neutral
by an institution like the CNCF where anyone
can contribute, you know, that is a document
that is always updated, that will ensure that
they're
vendor neutral, that they are objective,
they're not, you know, representing some
vendor's
view.
And so, yeah, I mean, it is changing
a lot. So that living aspect of it
is really important, and that's why I think
it will never end, Right. As cloud native
ends, you know? So there's always new technology
coming and yeah, and it's like as people
use it, that's our goal, right? As people
use it, you may because there's one approach,
right? Contributing to looking for specific terms that
you feel should be included, but my hope
or our hope is that as people use
it, right, you're using it because you wanna
cling to it or understand it or explain
it to someone, as you read it and
you're like, Arun, I actually think this could
be improved or this could be slightly better
or we could build on that. Right? Like
like, that's how it gets better. It's a
little bit like Wikipedia. Right? Wikipedia is really
good because so many people contribute. Right? And
the more people contribute to the glossary, the
better it will be. I think the foundation
is there, so we have a lot of
round covered.
But I'm pretty sure a lot can be
improved. I'm pretty sure we missed terms. So
Yeah. There are some terms that I really
wanna get out there, like get ups. Meaning
help with that, simplifying that, so if anyone
is interested in helping out with that term,
it's not merged yet. So
yeah, I mean, anyone interested in that. And
what Jason mentioned, really, it's explaining
complex
terms and simple words is really hard.
Right. It requires a lot of knowledge.
But it's really fun once you get there.
So it's not easy, but it's like and
it yeah. It's like once you see it,
once you
read it, and it's such a yeah. It's
just I I think it's like a joy
to read it, and it's like so digestible.
It's like, suddenly it sounds so easy, and
then yeah. Them. Yeah. Yeah. The one only
caveat I'd put out there, if you're thinking
about it, right, like, if you're gonna write
a definition for something, it's not, like, it's
not an entry level thing. Even though there's
no code, right, you really have to understand
what you're talking about in order to explain
it in a clear fashion. Just be warned
out there if you're thinking about contributing. That's
Yeah. Like a little bit of a misconception.
I think like the localization
aspect of this is good for entry level
contributors just because there is already a solid
Definition of the definition of And then localizing
is a lot easier in that sense. It's
still difficult. Like localizing well, but it's a
little easier. You don't need to be an
expert knowing it because someone did already that
research and
so, yeah. But it's fun. And, oh, the
other thing is like we have we have
monthly meetings where we meet with all the
different teams around the world. It's so exciting.
You have like people from China, from Korea,
India,
Spain,
South America, and Brazil.
It's like it's it's really cool and like
Yeah. That community, and we all try to
help each other, and they learn from each
other. I think that that is a little
bit special. Think that it is a little
bit more international because of that localization
aspect of it. And also, I know that
the Kubernetes has localization, but I don't think
they collaborate as much as our
localization team, and they don't know each other
as much. And so I know some of
them do localize the Kubernetes docs, and they've
said that. And I think that's kind of
nice. Meeting people all around the world. So
Yeah. It's pretty cool. So the origin story
for the glossary, right, like where did it
come from? You know, I I say this
a lot. Right? But it's really cool working
with Catherine
because, like, you know, most people, when you
see something that's messed up, right, like, oh,
that's funny. That's messed up or whatever. Right?
And you kinda move on. You know? So
Catherine and I started working together because she
saw the CNCF landscape talk and was like,
hey, you know, this is a giant mess
of things. It's hard to understand.
And she she was like, let me figure
out how to make it better. So she
started writing this article series on
explaining
the cloud native landscape in a clear fashion.
And so we started working together on that.
And as that grew and, you know, we
we actually started to make something really valuable,
we got involved with the CNCF. And and
Catherine's been working with the CNCF for a
while, but we're like, hey, there's a lot
of focus on technical value from the CNCF.
But what about, like, actual outcomes? What about
business value? And long story short, we set
up this business value committee within the CNCF.
And
when we set it up, we're like, hey,
what are some things we can do
to help the CNCF add value to businesses?
And one of the early ones that we
came up with was
a glossary of terms. Like, it would be
really helpful if there first thing. You need
to understand the concepts before you Yeah. You
need have common language. First yeah. Right? Like,
if you don't use if you and I
use a word
differently, the same word differently,
that's that's a barrier to understanding.
And so having having shared definitions seemed Yeah.
Like the best and most boring place to
start. Yeah. And I think, like, I mean,
the CNCF started out really as the like,
I mean, like, at the earlier on, like,
only the most technology advanced and highly skilled
engineers were interested in topics. So they had
all these content and very geeky, right, like
but so
much changed since then. Like, we're seeing so
much adoption. And as I mentioned before, you
have all these marketing and salespeople, all the
leadership team, all we have all these people
who are not necessarily technical,
but it's, for them, critical for their biz
like, business critical for them to understand it.
Otherwise, they cannot sell it. Otherwise they cannot
make the right decisions. But there was no
content that was, like, for them. So, like,
we also thought, like, because the first articles
that we did was for the new stack,
and that was great. That's where we got
a lot of feedback. And at some point,
we said, like, CNCF should own this type
of content. Like, why is I mean, it's
great. We love the news stack and we
appreciate appreciate the opportunity. But, like, the CNCF
is the eminence in this, you know, field,
and
they should kind of make it easier. How's
it work? I feel. Yeah. It's a little
too much. It's a very satisfying sound, though.
I really enjoy it. So I think one
of the things that
With the business value subcommittee,
right, do you believe
this is really a question because I don't
know the answer. Do you believe that the
CNCF is gonna do more things that focus
on
business leaders and help them understand the value
of the tech, not just the tech? So,
well, like, first of all, like, the business
value tracks
at coupon is something that came out from
our Yeah. And we so
we A of people come we did the
first we were the first reviewer for the
first because it was like a separate thing.
Yep.
So I think that is new.
It's still kind
of, well, is geared towards technical people too,
but it's talking about the business value, right?
And
I mean, the business value sub committee is
there to create these resources. So we we
create we have created
the glossary where
in the works
is a project summary table, which is still
not ready, but it basically puts like all
the projects in one category side by side,
and you can compare what they do. This
is not like business value, there's also like
a business case in it, but it's like
making sense of it or helping end users
actually select which projects they should evaluate, and
that came because like a service provider mentioned
it is so difficult for them to, like
the landscape is overwhelming,
he does not know which projects are relevant
for their clients, it's like you either have
the landscape which just just give you a
name, and then you have like deep dives,
and there's not like how do you, like,
they need an overview, it's like to understand
like, okay, a, b, c look interesting, I'm
gonna evaluate those. And it's really hard to
kind of see what's relevant. And so that's
like an end user request,
right, like, or or need, so we try
to cater to that. And then now we're
also building
cloud native learning journey,
which is basically a page that will have
all these CMCF resources
bundled and it will start with content that
doesn't require
any previous knowledge, right? So it's like, okay,
if you're very new, this is the one
on one section, start with the cloud native
definition, then maybe the glossary, and then gets
increasingly more advanced to really help people in
their cloud native learning journey instead of having
to find all these resources on from
themselves. So I think most of that content
is not like initiated
by the CNCF, but like groups like ours,
that's where people can tell. And most of
them is like generally people say like, oh,
this is a problem I've had. And then
we were like, okay, you're having this problem,
someone else probably having this problem. Like, let's
solve this together. Like, let's create something that
helps you, and in that way help other
people too. So so I don't think yeah.
It's not CNCF driven in that sense, but
it's like these these groups kind of create
there are a lot of groups. Why the
cartographers group is another group that created like
the Cloud Native Maturity Model
and all these things. So there are all
these people who volunteer,
contribute to open source without codes, and non
code contributions, also very important and very valuable.
So Yep. There are a lot of initiatives.
Right? And so what we wanna do is
make it easier for people to find that.
And just to add add a little bit
to what Catherine said, right, like you can
see with, you know, the things that the
business value community came out with, You see
with the emphasis in talks at KubeCon, right,
more more user stories and getting getting out
of vendor stuff. That certification that's meant to
be, like, hey, you're new to this space.
Let's give you a baseline
a baseline
conversational
knowledge that you need to to have those
hallway track conversations with a lot of folks
have been in the space for a long
time kinda take take for granted. So I
think I think the CNCF is absolutely working
to
better explain the
real value, not this not just the technological
value, but the outcome value of projects things.
Super supportive. The thing is, like, the CNCF
is small. They have a very small team.
Right? And they are they depend, let's say,
on the community
to help and support. And like once you
have a good idea and they believe in
it, they really give you the resources, right?
Like to create a glossary, you need someone
to develop the website, and so we get
all the resources which is amazing, and then
the PR team, like that's where my marketing
sales comes, like I know what needs to
be done, and then the PR team is
amazing, and then they're like, you know, like
I don't know, they write a blog post
or talk to reporters, and like, so they
make the resources available to to help get
the word out, which is, so I think
it's great. I've really enjoyed working with the
CNCF. Alright. So you want me to to
define service mesh? I'm gonna do it off
the top of my head. I'm not gonna
look it up. Right? But
a service mesh is
according to the the glossary definition, and somebody
look me up as you're watching this and
and laugh at how wrong I am. But
it is it is a tool that
uses
uses effectively
a
don't think it has to be a sidecar,
but uses a series of load balancers
to
route your traffic from an application through to
this other process. Right?
Let me start again. A a service mesh
exists to take
the platform level infrastructure
that your applications need when you're gonna run-in
a microservice environment and
take that code or that tooling that allows
you to do a good job at service
discovery,
secure your traffic over the network, do circuit
breaking, do timeouts, do retries, take it out
of your application code so you're not doing
it in a shared library and instead put
it in a separate process,
route your traffic through that process,
and give them the responsibility
for core
usability on the network features for your app
to
something that can be managed by your platform
team. At its core, it's intended to allow
platform teams to deliver
more value to application development teams
by reducing their operational overhead and giving them
better performance, better security for their applications.
So but look it up and feel free
to mock me. It's less technical in the
Yeah. Glossary. Yeah. I'll put it on the
screen underneath just as you go around. Thank
you. Yeah. Great.
Do I do we think everybody that's using
Kubernetes should have a service mesh?
No. I don't think everybody needs to have
one, and I try not to deal in
shoulds in a general sense.
But
I think for most folks that are using
that are using Kubernetes,
right, like, a little bit of a story.
Right? Like, I used to work at a
company and we had we had a service
mesh based on one of the big one
of the really well known service mesh products
out there. I won't I won't name it.
Right? And, you know, we used to tell
folks,
like, get get Kubernetes figured out first because
it's hard. And then you add in a
service mesh and it's harder. Right? And that's
that's a thing that a lot of folks
deal with as they begin that as they
begin that journey.
And since I've been at Boeing, partly because,
it's my job to tell you to use
Linkerd e, right, but I came here because
I believe Linkerd e is good. I'll tell
you, is a tool that in my view
and in my experience with customers that adopt
it, it makes Kubernetes easier.
So if you're doing
REST based services, you're doing gRPC applications, and
you're running in Kubernetes,
this is a tool you can add to
your environment
to enhance
the capabilities of your platform
and to make life, like, make life easier
for yourselves and your developers. Right? And that's
that's pretty that's pretty awesome. So if if
you're building custom apps,
I would recommend a service mesh. If your
cluster is intended exclusively to host infrastructure components
like your registry, your CICD system, other like
vendor products that vendors are responsible for the
core code,
then I don't think I don't think a
service mesh is particularly important unless you're
have, like, a high security regulatory requirement for
encryption in transit. And even then, you could
probably bug your vendor to, like, use
HPS calls between their components. Right? That's that's
my view on that. I don't know if
you have anything to add. No.
It's like, I mean, it's more of a
technical part. Yeah. Because like, I hear it
all the time that a lot of people
say, like, service metrics are are think that
it's so overly complex How complicated. That then
play try Linkerd and it's not. I, course,
cannot
have experimented with it because I don't code.
But it's like,
apparently, it is a lot easier than a
lot of people think. And if you get
a lot of value out of it, and
we always say, like, just give it a
try and it's for Don't
believe us. Just just try it Right. And
then you'll see. Best features of Linkerd you
know, the thing that I tell people is
we think Linkerd is awesome because
it's boring. Right? Like, I think the best
feature of Linkerd is
you can have something
that runs in Kubernetes, install Linkerd,
add that thing, that application
to the mesh,
and it still works. Right? I
think I think that's fantastic.
Beyond that, right, like, somewhat,
whatever tongue in cheek value point. Right? Mucil
TLS,
like, having a
guarantee that every conversation in your cluster between
components
is gonna be encrypted
and both the client and the server are
gonna be positively identified
using cryptographic identity, I think is really
a big deal. Right? Like, the thing that
you trust to do mobile banking, the thing
that you trust to, you know, browse whatever
secure thing you need to do on the
Internet is the foundation of trust they can
use in your cluster between your components.
And that's hugely powerful.
And, you know, third,
it depends what you're doing, but I like
I'll tell you, I had a terribly painful
experience before
Kubernetes trying to get trying to get 15
different app teams to all write a slash
metrics endpoint in their app and put some
sort of comparable
data. So I could look at app a
and app b and see similar results. And
that was brutally hard. With with BlinkerD, you
get the same metrics for every single application
without any
without bothering any developers,
which is my favorite thing. I, I hate
trying to get people who are trying to
develop a feature to instead stop what they're
doing and build plumbing. Right? That was
it was not a great experience.
Yeah. So you're asking about what's what's next
with Linkerd and and specifically around Linkerd and
the Gateway API. So really exciting,
I guess. Exciting is gonna depend on who
you are. What I find exciting from a
technical perspective
is
there has been a move with Linkerd to
add things like policy, let you do header
based routing, let you do some more intelligent
things with your traffic. But we're trying to
balance that new set of features with, you
know, the thing that Linkerd has always been
famous for, which is simplicity, not having a
ton of custom resource definitions. Right? Things like
that. And the gateway API project
came along at a incredibly
good time for us. Right? And and it
turns out that the primitives that the gateway
API gives you in your Kubernetes class there
are exactly the sort of things that you
don't just need from an ingress perspective,
but that you want in order to manage
traffic
east west between your applications.
And
we're adopting the constructs in Linkerd. I think
by 02/14,
we expect to be a % gateway API
compliant,
right, which is which is really exciting. And
it it's gonna allow us to do
do policy, do header based routing, do traffic
splitting, do all of it with
no, you know, without any new linkerdy isms
in your cluster.
No adopting, no changing the way you work
to fit our mesh. Right? Which is the
reason we're easy to use today, and it's
the way we're gonna be able to give
new features to folks out there while keeping
that same promise.
Yeah. Great question. Thank you so much. So,
where do you go to learn more about
Linkerd? Well,
I biased towards Slack,
slack.linkerd.io.
You can join up. You meet other folks
that are doing linker d. Talk to us.
See if you have, you know, commentary about
how badly I messed up the service mesh
definition. I'm at Jason on the linker d
Slack. You can find us on Twitter, just
at linker d.
We have a website, linkerd.io,
where you can learn more. That's where all
our docs are. Our getting started guide, which
is fantastic.
You can go get Linkerd up and running
in a Kubernetes cluster. If it takes you
thirty minutes, let me know. I'll also apologize
for that.
And we have Service Mesh Academy. Oh, oh,
right. If you go to Boynton, sorry. Go
ahead. Yeah. Yeah. So if you're interested in
getting, like, hands on experience
with Linkerd, once a month, we have a
live workshop. And, yeah, like, topics. Next topic
is GitOps with Flagr,
Flux, and Liberty.
So really excited about that. I think that's
next week. But,
yeah, like, every month there is, a new
topic. It's % open source.
Yeah. And they're they're, like, technical deep dives.
Right? So you're gonna you're gonna really get
to know a particular component of Linkerd and
the way it works. Like, I learned a
ton when we talked about certificates and the
way we do routing,
and I could just really highly recommend it.
Yeah. Well, yeah. For sure. Like, thanks a
ton for for having us. We really appreciate
it. Thank you. You know, it's been a
it's been a great conference. It's been great
getting to hang out a little bit. So
Yeah. We've loved it. Yeah. Thanks so much
for having us and and letting us share
our
little pet project and talk about VingerDee. I
really appreciate the opportunity. Thank you, Dave. Yeah.